[Music]
my name is morality Allah I'm a director
of product management at starid Ichi and
I'm presenting today with my colleague
Paul right here thank you
so what we'll be talking about today is
why you might want to virtualize your
workstations we'll show you how you can
damage it if damaged and manage it
efficiently and we'll have a great demo
that Paul will show and hopefully five
to ten minutes of questions at the end
as well okay some of you are familiar
with EEG some are not so I wanted to do
a quick overview who we are as a company
for you so we were founded in 2004 at
which time we invented a revolutionary
new protocol for remoting desktops of
workstations called PC or IP and since
then we now have about 13 million users
worldwide directly through us or through
our OEM partnerships and these customers
are deploying on-premises and public
clouds hybrid environments all sorts of
mixed environments like that and
customers include fortune 500 companies
across many different industries so
federal government for example media
entertainment manufacturing education
finance and more also as a company will
work very closely with technology
partners like Google like Nvidia in
order to provide the best solutions for
our customers okay so getting into the
workstation use cases so here are a few
use cases for high performance remote
workloads these are a lot of these are
our customers that we've seen and how
they use it across the different
verticals so I'll go through all of them
media entertainment example would be
visual effects workloads a video
tutorial so creating movies and
and frightening movies creating visual
effects for movies federal government
examples here for workstations the car
GPUs would be data modeling simulation
so for example flight vehicle training
and simulation geospatial mapping those
are examples they're manufacturing and
engineering generally CAD workloads 3d
and 2d CAD workloads
this is automotive as well as
architecture engineering construction
type of firms and actually also at
autonomous driving development fits in
there as well for finance it would be
trading generally trading requires high
performance they also have a lot of very
large screens at their desks and for
higher education most workstation use
cases for higher education would be
around STEM subjects so science
technology engineering and math and
things like lab work online learning and
training and testing for STEM subjects
as well and for healthcare it's a
primarily medical imaging okay so what
are the key challenges that these type
of customers face when they have
workstation high performance or clothes
so number one that we see the most often
is that they need to protect their
valuable IP so imagine I mean the
entertainment studio creating next
Avengers they don't want spoiler to leak
out in the federal government they don't
want any classified data to leak out so
it's that really is number one for all
of those use cases I described another
one is on-site Hardware is expensive
just scale and manage so if you are
purchasing workstations there under the
desk if you need to scale grow hire more
people contractors maybe our vendors
need to get access and work with you
it's it's it's more complicated to you
have to wait six weeks to get the
workstation and you may not need it all
the
did you get your Aria are I on it it's a
common problem as well and then modern
and mobile workforces are demanding
offset access so this is this is people
collaborating this is people wanting to
work from home it's it's more and more
common have that work-life balance and
wood workstations the 3d models the
graphics intensive workloads the content
itself is increasing in size as well as
complexity so when teams and different
vendors or contractors have to
collaborate together it's it's more and
more difficult because the the content
itself is more complex and there's
there's a need to have geographically
dispersed teams you might want to hire
people from different locations in the
world because of cost savings because of
you know company may have purchased
another company lots of reasons okay so
some of the those are the challenges and
here I covered how virtual workstations
can address those challenges these are
not all of them and there's a lot more
to it but these are a few highlighted
ones and this is together with public
cloud like Google as well as our PCP
technology and all the benefits you get
out of it one is that it improves
productivity and efficiency so now that
your your workstation is no longer under
your desk it somewhere else is
consolidated in a public cloud or in a
data center you get to access it from
anywhere that means you can have those
dispersed teams you don't you don't need
to worry about different team members
downloading data to their workstation to
work on it and then upload it uploading
so the other person can see what what
changed it's just just more efficient
this way and and working from home it
this be lots of case studies done
studies done around that how it improves
efficiency in collaboration by 25
percent or more so it's a it's generally
a more efficient way to work and lastly
it does enable companies to hire
global talent from anywhere so they're
not they don't have to feel that labor
pinch having to locally higher in
whatever office they're in and whatever
city dairy and they can hire anywhere
and benefit even from taxes tax
deductions as well another one is that
you can realize I'm president and
security and protect your IP so with our
technology when you remote your
workstation somewhere else
firstly again you're not downloading the
data so it's not somewhere on a device
that somebody's taking traveling with
working from home with it's your data is
somewhere safe in the cloud or the data
center and with our technology what we
do is we look at that desktop that you
are working with in like an application
Autodesk Maya or AutoCAD or something
like that
we just encrypt an encode the desktop
and we we transmit only encrypted pixels
to the client device not the actual data
so your data is protected in a cloud it
never gets sent to the client device
that's really important and second is
using Google Cloud I mean as you have
seen at the keynote and a lot of the
sessions here they put a lot of effort
into security like compliances
certifications encryption of your data a
lot of products that are offer around
security so the combination of the two
makes it more secure by virtualizing it
also increases your agility and
scalability so you can get on-demand
access to latest tech all the time and
as much of it as you want because you
are so for example Nvidia launched a new
GPU t4 and you get to utilize it
immediately rather than wait for it to
be for you to order it to arrive it to
get it and use it and and hopefully with
when you purchase something on premises
you hopefully will use it all the time
otherwise you don't get you all ride
with public cloud you you get to scale
use it a lot of it and then if you don't
use it anymore you don't you don't pay
for it anymore it's that up X versus
capex model and the benefits of that and
lastly
by virtualizing over station you really
realize the full potential of the cloud
so you're moving your data to the cloud
consolidating your data with your
compute sole the compute power for
rendering high performance computing and
but you're not doing the work station so
you now whatever your result is a rear
end or now you have to download it and I
work on it don't know it's an
application and when you move your app
collocate your data you compute a new
graphics you move your application your
workstation where your data is you you
you get to benefit fully from the cloud
and really this is only possible if when
you utilize when you are virtualizing
they do have that really great user
experience you can expect your
high-performance users to you know use
the workstation sluggish or there's
distortions on it that's what we come in
we ensure that their performance is as
if it's under the desk rather than
somewhere else
okay so white or DC by our technology
I've heard a little bit of previously on
it but this is a bit more detail based
on our workstation customers and what
their needs are so high performance your
experience what we do is our protocol
provides the highest image quality with
efficient built a lossless so what that
means is when you're looking at an image
virtualized and on-premises it's 100
stack color accurate lossless now I
built the lossless and highly
interactive and low latency which is
which is what these type of users really
really need also what we do in terms of
high precision experience is that we
automatically adjust to changing natural
conditions so if your users are you know
working home or traveling wherever they
are using a tablet maybe somewhere in
the field like example would be a
architect going on-site and looking at
his 3d drawings on his tablet well the
network is very different from when he's
in the office we are America just and
the best user experience there's no need
to you know do some change settings etc
we also offer also secure remoting and
input architecture like I said we just
encrypt and transmit pixels aes-256
encryption as well and no data ever ever
gets to the client device again I'll
emphasize here and one of our verticals
is the federal government it's quite a
big vertical for us because of the
security we offer with our technology
and also ease of deployment and
management we understand that if you
have if you're managing virtual
workstations you want to make sure that
you can do that efficiently and
effectively and we do that as well with
the tools we provide you and Paul will
demonstrate that later on as well and we
also support wireless widest platform
flexibility so this would be this means
multi cloud this means any public cloud
on-premises mix of those whatever suits
your needs we we can do ok so I haven't
said yet for the product it's called
it's called cloud as a software to Rishi
cloud as a software and it's built on
top of the piece ERP talk technology
that I've been talking about ok I wanted
to bring this up because it was also
brought up at the Tuesday keynote as
well that that enterprises have a multi
cloud strategy either have it now
already our multi cloud or going multi
clouds so this is a pretty high
percentage 84% so if you were thinking
about going to the cloud and you're
worried it's quite common to have a
mixed environment where certain projects
go to the cloud maybe you burst into the
cloud or you might be so I'm fully in
the cloud it's it's it's up to you and
your business so this year shows that
with cloud access software we support
all phases of your journey to the cloud
whether you want to be just on the data
center today virtualized or not
virtualized and there's this burst and
cloud a little bit or go fully to the
cloud or whatever you are today or where
you want to go later we can support all
the scenario
already so speaking of that hybrid
environment here's an example
architecture as you can see an
on-premises and a public cloud version
version workstations
so the on-premises there is one the
shows to the show overt virtualized and
a hypervisor is xio or KVM hypervisor
and also non-virtualized once I know the
public cloud Google Cloud you have some
VMs as well and what the that's where we
install our software and what the user
end-user would do that's sitting at
their desk working on let's say a CAD
workload they would basically install a
software client on their laptop it can
be any it's our workstation style
laptops just a lower level laptop Mac
Windows Linux whatever as well as mobile
Chrome OS Android iOS tablets and the
pizza p0 client which is a hardware
client device that we have that has our
chip in it and no application OS so
those are the choice for example for
education they might be using
Chromebooks to a Chromebook to connect
to Autodesk AutoCAD or something running
in the public cloud so they're using a
simple Chromebook to do that sort of
high intensity work okay so let's say
you do virtualize your workstations and
if you do you need a need a way to
efficiently manage them and there's
reasons why you might want to visually
manage and obviously save time and money
to manage your users what we offer is
cloud access manager service for you to
be able to do this and this is what Paul
will demonstrate as well and some of the
features and capabilities that it gives
you is that it improves administrative
efficiency because it automatically
provisions your workstations for you so
you don't have to manually go through a
bunch of steps to do it you can scale
easily you can add more workstations to
remove workstations scale up and down
easily and third one on there is about
managing cloud consumption costs so
that's
big thing if you are using a public
cloud and you're using the OP X versus
capex model you want to and need to you
don't want to be paying for something
you're not currently using so cloud
access manager helps with that if you're
not using it it's shut down so you're
not paying for compute and the user
wants to use their workstation you can
just log in and get access to it oh and
of course lastly it's that it's brokers
the connection from the user to the
workstation so when I log in to my
client
I'm presented only with desktops that
I've been authorized to access access by
my administrator ok I won't cover all
these but I want to cover a couple of
them that our workstation customers care
about 4k uhd resolution we do support
that so most customers are still HD but
they're going to 4k for various reasons
could be content they're working on is
4k could be just they need a real estate
so they buy in for kids and it's
becoming cheaper and cheaper we support
both Windows and Linux environments so
when I was talking about all those use
cases some of them are some use cases
are purely Windows the applications
they're using are only running on
Windows some of them are purely Linux
some are mixed we don't care it works
with all of them and additionally we I
know we're talking about workstations
here but we support also normal normal
users like office workers and task
workers as well not just workstation
users we have a version of our software
for that too and we this is an example
of something where we put an effort into
providing low latency peripheral support
so some of our users in media
entertainment for example need to use
tablets like this and it's very
important to them that that feels like
it's right there rather than they feel
the monitors are calm 20 minutes
millisecond latency between the user and
the workstation they feel it
can use it so we develop technology to
make that feel like it's under the desk
this is a little bit of advertising and
we introduced and announced last week
peop altra this is our latest protocol
enhancements in terms of performance we
as you can see we continuously improve
our performance based on the needs of
the workstation users in the industry is
changing so this latest upgrade means
forex encoder performance so you could
do 4k resolutions that up to 60 frames
per second here's an example what our
customers are saying Sony Pictures
Imageworks is one of our long time users
of our technology and you can see here
I'll read it out Terry cheek Odyssey
software on Google cloud will allow us
to rapidly scale and burst virtual
workstations for our visual effects
artists using NVIDIA GPU cloud instances
enabling our studio to meet tight
project timelines it's that one I was
talking about earlier one of the
benefits of utilizing virtual
workstations and power cloud is that you
get a competitive competitive edge
against against your competitors is
another customer you can read a lot more
about this one on our website but just
wanted to highlight one thing that
they've benefited from as well that I
didn't talk about earlier a day when I
moved the workstation away from the
artists Saturday desk somewhere else
they said that the working environment
was so much more pleasant because it's
quieter there's no heavy work stations
it's just a simple clients that they're
working with and it felt cooler as well
because with the workstation it was it
was quite hot in the rooms or they were
working right so if you want to try it
out to call us a software we do have it
on a GCP marketplace that's one way to
try it out you can also reach out to us
and get get a trial Isis as well outside
of this
and I also want to call out the Nvidia
has also released a google cloud
marketplace image for their quadrille
virtual workstation for their tea for so
it's it's something you could try it out
today if you use it you can access
remotely access it with our technology
it's available looks like in eight
different regions just to show you this
is a demo it's a really cool demo that
they have at their booth if you all at
the end I'll show a slide of the
different boosts that you could visit
that have our technology in it there's
several and this is one you could go you
could go see okay so that was it a my
part I think you're probably all waiting
for a demo Paul
go ahead great can everyone hear me okay
great yeah thanks a lot Mel Morello so
what I'm gonna be doing this morning is
I'm going to show you well if we can
just switch back to the slides for a
quick sec that would be appreciated
I'm gonna show you the architecture of
what I've set up and what I'm going to
demo and so what I've got is two
different regions where I've got remote
workstations in GC p US East another
region remote workstation setup and GCP
West and I've also got remote
workstation setup on premises since
we're in Vancouver I decided to put them
in Vancouver for this demo and and so
what we require is for you as users of
piece or P to install this connector we
call it the cloud access connector and
that effectively allows your PC VIP
clients to connect directly to your
remote work stations these room clients
as Marilla said are we support various
types of devices the charity g0 client
the PCIP client running on Windows Linux
OS 10 iOS and Android devices but when
when you connect into your remote
workstations we don't require the use of
a VPN inside the cloud access connector
we have a secure security gateway the
effectively acts as a NAT and also to
what is connected to the cloud
this connector is your directory service
currently we support Microsoft ad we
will be supporting other directory
services in their near future and I was
really happy to hear giggles
announcement yesterday where their
support for Microsoft dat as well um so
and what coordinates all of this is
we've developed a cloud access manager
service that runs in the cloud you have
a single management console to go to it
to administer all these machines as well
as entitle users to those machines I'm
just gonna geek out for you a geek Oh
for a couple seconds but I'm really
proud what we developed this cloud
access manager service was developed as
a cloud native application right from
the beginning we built it on top of
kubernetes we've embraced all the
principles between sre and DevOps as
well as we've built it as a 12 factor
app lots of exciting things happening in
the cloud world and we're happy that we
could take advantage of that so now if
we can jump on to the demo computer that
would be great what I'm going to do is
I'm just going to show you a piece of IP
connection quickly just so you get a
sense of what it's like and then I'm
going to show you our administration
console and as you can see we run on
even old laptops as such as this one
here so I'm this again I've got our
piece of IP client already installed on
this Windows laptop I'm gonna kind of go
through the manual connection dish to
show you how we do it so I'm just going
to type in the IP address sorry I had it
in my buffer but I guess I got lost and
so this is the IP address of the cloud
access connector that is in your
subscription okay and so I'm going to
enter in my credentials make sure I get
it right and I have to admit as I was
preparing for this presentation I found
myself constantly speaking out loud my
password so I apologize if I do that
today okay so I've been authenticated
against my 80 credentials I'm presented
with a list of remote workstations that
have been previously authorized to
access so I'm just going to jump on to
this one and do a connection and so
what's happening now is the PC IP
connection is being directly established
through the cloud axis connected to the
remote workstation in your subscription
on GCP so here you can see I've got a
Windows a Windows machine running this
is on a I've got the Nvidia so I think I
selected the Nvidia a virtual
workstation with the P for GPU and this
is you know just to kind of highlight
you know all the different things that
you can do with the remote workstation
here so I'll just make sure and one
thing I like to kind of demo and I'll
see if I can demo it quickly since this
is a live demo but I'll just see if I
can go to it I've got a speed I'm just
gonna run this speed test in the
background I'm I just chose this one as
it's running I just want to highlight
you know if your date is in the cloud
and your visualize or your doing your
analysis in the cloud and you're
visualizing the cloud why not actually
have you desktop in the cloud as well
and so here you see the download speed
I'm getting just you know just around
one gigabit or just slightly below one
gigabit per second and now I'm gonna do
my upload speed and it's kind of
creeping up towards one gigabit so yeah
so I just wanted to kind of highlight
that in the Layton sees again if you've
got your data in the cloud and you got
your remote workstations in a cloud the
latency is between them can be actually
very low and I'm just going to show you
and I'll keep that running in the
background and I'm just going to connect
to another remote workstation I'll do
the same thing as before the same IP
address oops that's not the same sorry
about that okay and I'll enter the same
credentials as I entered in before
and I'm going to select a different
workstation and i'll connect to it now
yeah okay and here it is yeah okay so
this is a different workstation but you
can see it's not Windows here I'm
running sent to s7 on GCP with an nvidia
p4 as well so we support um
Rell and for people in the crowd who are
developer types I know that you per for
prefer Ubuntu and we support that as
well
and here's just another simple WebGL
application that I like to quickly demo
just kind of shows the capabilities of
the GPU very very quick so that's really
neat to see cool so how do we make this
happen so I'm gonna log into the cloud
access manager portal MIT's at kmbc.com
today I'm actually showing you our beta
UI and that's why it's represented in
the URL we support a different identity
providers to log in and we support
Microsoft and Google since we're at
Google next I'm gonna log in with Google
so I've got my tier DG demo account on
Gmail I'm just gonna login didn't ask me
for my password I just logged in about
20 minutes ago so with the cloud access
manager there's there's three kind of
concepts there's deployments connectors
and remote workstations remote
workstations I'll get to in a second but
with deployments say you're in match
service provider where you're managing
different customer accounts on their
behalf in that case you would want to
have multiple deployments per customer
where the ad is connected to each you'd
have a different ad in different cloud
credentials to provision those machines
another example of where you'd want
multiple deployments is so you want an
area for your sandbox environment so you
can do all your sandbox testing before
modifying your production environment
another example is disaster recovery you
might want to set up set up entirely
different deployment for your dr site
and then connectors these are the three
connectors that I was showing in that
architecture diagram earlier we've got
the Vancouver on premise one and Ora on
premises one the GCP u.s. East in the
GCP u.s. West and you can monitor the
health of the connector especially if
the connector goes down and then from
the connector there's a couple different
things you can do is you can create a
new remote workstation crewmate creating
a remote workstation is where you would
provision a remote workstation where we
would do that on your behalf and we
would install the software install the
Nvidia drivers if you decide to use the
graphics agent machine as well as
actually added to the domain such that
you can have your users log in with a
single sign-on user experience so I'm
just gonna kind of quickly show what it
looks like for the simple user interface
so here I've got I'm gonna select and
select the windows or a graphics machine
just to enter my name and then since
I've already set this up with GCP here
all the different regions and zones that
you can select from I'm just going to
select a region where I know there's GCC
or Nvidia machines I've already set up
my networking so I'm just going to
select my Network I'll just choose that
one and then machine type you can select
different types and then here the
different GPU type so today in this
region I see the Tesla P 100 and the P
for a couple days ago Nvidia announced
the T 4 which is really exciting as well
and once that becomes available in the
region it will automatically show up in
our interface here so I'll just select
the P 4 and you can select how many GPUs
you would like and then just a daydream
I could ad credentials this is a service
account credentials so I'll just do it
quickly
about that rate and then I'm gonna get
hit create so while that's going off in
the background I'm just gonna go and
show you the view of the remote
workstations page so these are the three
remote workstations I've previously
setup as well as the one that's being
created right now so you can see they're
running and so with most you know
virtual workstations you might be
familiar with you can start stop restart
and delete them as well as edit so I'm
just going to edit one just to quickly
show you here is all my users in my ad
so I can assign Ryan Meadows and Adam
add him to this list such that when he
logged in with his ad credentials he'll
be presented with this remote
workstation it's like so this person can
go access it and one thing I want to
mention this whole front end that you're
seeing is using our back-end dpis and we
plan to make those back in EP is
publicly available for our partners this
can be really useful if you're wanting
to build your own solution on top of
ours so you can add your own value adds
you might be wanting to automate a lot
of this stuff well I expect you will so
using those api's you can automate it
and actually not have to go through this
UI but the UI is really good wait it's
just to show how things are set up as
well as from monitoring things and I'm
just gonna quickly show the power
management side of things so here's a
machine that is in the stop state and
what I'm going to do I'm gonna start up
a third piece for IP session I'll enter
in the same IP address as before
okay and the Machine I believe was
staged VFX one that's in the stop state
yes it is okay so I'm just gonna go
connect to it establish a piece of IP
connection and so what you'll see me
just Oh so back in the client it said it
was actually starting now if I go back
to the remote workstations it says it's
starting here one of the neat things
about the GCP machines is they they
start up really fast so within less than
a minute this machine will be running
and then your user will automatically
connect to it yeah it's important to
keep control of your cost because
running machines in the cloud especially
did you the GPU ones I can run up a
large bill so some users like to turn
them off when they're not being used ok
[Music]